adam ali elisha and cannon have hit the
road to find a suitable location for a
flattest fueled rocket launch that's not
a sentence he hear every day I am
currently standing at southeastern end
of San Francisco Bay at the tri-cities
landfilled
we have had many shenanigans on the
properties of waste management we've
launched duct-tape trebuchet 'z yep
Adam and Jamie proved their favourite
material is pretty handy if you ever
need to sling a flaming projectile at an
inflatable great white shark
we hit it it's burning
we've even set fires in fake kitchens
and doused them with helicopters full of
water grannies on fire too
that excursion busted the myth that by
dousing a kitchen grease fire with water
a chopper load for mythbustery good
measure does not create a fireball today
we are launching rockets using only my
farts what could be better let's get to
it this myth is all about testing if
outers farts are a viable combustible
fuel I would say if we get a good
liftoff on that rocket his farts are
looking pretty good the rip one rocket
is ready it's been given an aerodynamic
makeover by Elijah and Canada and has
the all-important nozzle for efficient
thrust Ali had some amazing results
experimenting with different ratios of
oxygen to fart gas and more testing with
her best ratio from the parking lot and
that vital stoichiometry is 60% Adam
adding fart gas now to 40% oxygen you
know after this Ali you can tell people
that you're an amateur rocket scientists
okay
let's go let's go the flattest flight
crew touch base with launch control all
right here will you radio back to base
camp for an ignition check copy yes
could we get an ignition check please
yes you can thank you
ignition check in three two one and a
fully loaded rocket is set into the
gantry this rocket looks amazing so far
it looks like we're going to get liftoff
so hold on to your butts all right we're
locked and loaded you guys ready yeah
can't wait for this so hopefully I've
liftoff what do you think you think it's
gonna work I think this might have a
chance at possibly working what do you
think I have no clue what's gonna happen
but it's gonna be good that's a hedging
your bets like a Hyneman all right all
right iliza count it in all right
full-scale for rocket testing three two
one
[Laughter]
amazing oh wow - like for 30 or 40 feet
I think crazy it also stayed on a
ballistic trajectory when I rock it went
34 feet into the air and traveled at 38
miles per hour it shot way higher than I
could have ever imagined and it was just
the weirdest thing to think that it was
powered by flatulence Adam your farts
blew me away
[Laughter]